what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i have my brother adam on the
channel
and he has never seen the manosphere
never even heard of it until
she told me about it um so i'm going to
give them your stats as a guy
he's tall right um there's no women on
my channel
so that's like that's not the reason oh
um
i would say he's on his way to making
money someday but he's still young
he's 21 in college oh my gosh
still struggling with the nine to five
we're in the line waiting to get
starbucks
yeah she got me starbucks i'm not i'm
not a hard bribe
here you go double chocolate chip
frappuccino
okay adam so first question i have
what is your ideal age range to date
after age plus seven what so what is
that what you're twenty-four
eight seventeen hopefully you round up
so it's roughly a four-year difference i
was being
kind of joking about it so like like 18
to to what i wouldn't date anyone under
18 right now i'm not like how old cause
they say that guys don't like girls
older than them
i could date a 25 year old really
i could date a 27 year old would you
marry a 25 year old like you found a
girl that you really liked
because dating and mary is two different
things
that is true um my thing is i don't
really date
that's most girls that he's a [ __ ] boy
i wouldn't necessarily say that that's
that that might be a little further than
what i am but i do
don't really necessarily like the date
um
there's too much restriction that's how
i put it what does that mean
um i just feel wrong if i'm even talking
to another woman
and like not in the sense of actually
trying to sleep with them or anything
just like
in general as a guy oh you mean like
even as a friend yeah it's a
conversation in general so that's where
i find dating to be
so you'd rather like get all the
benefits of dating yeah
get all the benefits without actually
having to do anything for him but he
lets the girls know
he lets them know and make sure they
know um they may slowly hate him over
time
um okay next question okay do you think
um
body count matters oh yeah and what how
many is too many
more than me wait what are you like if
you're beating me then black man
what are you at i'm not admitting that
over
a lot more or less than 20. higher
so as long as she was a lower body count
than you what if she had one lower than
you would you be freaked out
no i'd laugh you'd be like [ __ ] all
right i'll keep my number higher because
i'm sleeping with you
the moment i hear your number goes up
well so she had one more than you then
you'd be like no
cyan or a [ __ ] within a few
okay without like maybe like five i
think that i slept with more
people than i needed to but um
but you can't really judge her if you
did the same thing yeah
okay the man of sphere would disagree we
all make mistakes that's my opinion on
it
okay next question
do you think that guys should be allowed
to cheat if they make a lot of money and
they're paying for
everything no cheating is wrong all the
way around i
[ __ ] that would you ever stay with the
girl that cheated on you
because you dumped the last bit
two two not the last one the one before
last one i mean i still kind of talked
to
okay see in the menosphere they think
it's okay to cheat
when you have options and you're like
paying for everything because they feel
like
basically you're trading like your
resources for women's like goods and
services like
loyalty basically um okay but next
question next question
next question um do
you
who do you think has it harder in dating
men are women
by far you think they have it harder
really why
um my favorite i forgot who said this
my favorite thing was um if someone
finds it quote them
okay it was men or women get to choose
who they sleep with men get to choose
who they marry
right well i actually i think it's
harder for women for two reasons right
women have a clock that's ticking and
so even even when you're young like i
don't need to be married tomorrow right
but i'm well aware that i don't have
like i have less than a decade to like
figure out who i'm going to marry
because at 35 it's like a high-risk
pregnancy
so you got you gotta get your [ __ ]
figured out before that
and the second reason i think it's
harder for women is it's very hard to
decipher the difference
um between someone giving you attention
and wanting to like date you
or just like yeah oh sorry yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're men
i guess it's hard for men too though
because some rose will definitely use
them for like food
food funny yeah but for men it's a lot
more obvious because you're able to
you can be a lot more clear about hey
you can you just take away the things
that they
that you provide the most for them and
you see how they react and that's easy
to face i'm gonna go over here while we
finish this video
it's easy to gauge how you can figure
out if someone's using you very quickly
just by taking a thing or two away
versus woman's
say i lost my job see if she stands yeah
versus woman if
take away sex or taking away it for both
of you it's not just
yeah one staff like if i stop paying for
hannah's meals
all it does is give me more money like
that's nothing bad
for me but like when do you pay for my
meals okay
we're siblings i was just hitting it for
sure i know i know i know well
and like i feel like girls they you have
the risk that if you sleep with them he
could just
ghost you tomorrow and then you've given
up like
you know um another number
um okay what other questions are they
gonna ask you
in the manusphere
so i asked you about so wait how so you
go up to 25. did you say you'd marry a
25 year old
yeah okay yeah they'd have to be amazing
but
they'd have to make up for it just i
don't
i don't think i never marry someone
that isn't amazing overall yeah
okay what about um do you care about a
girl's money
not really so she doesn't care about
money
all together but do you care about her
ambition
yeah she has to be driven motivated as
hell
um if i start a business tomorrow she
has to be willing to help me
run it and work through it and just put
up with my [ __ ] while i'm doing it
like you can't just can't be someone
that sits there and hey
yeah cheerleader what if what if she
started a business would you be willing
to go and help her
oh really so you'd be cool with like
going on like hurt like if she had a
business going you'd be totally good
would you be cool if she made more money
than you
yeah i'd be a little upset but yeah
if she was paying for my [ __ ] i wouldn't
care she's super competitive so i feel
like i feel like you would i feel like
you would try to like
beat her i would i would that is true
i'm very competitive
but growing up this uh austin and
everybody's siblings were gonna be
competitive like
okay what are your deal breakers
um it doesn't want
kids that's it
i don't know if i want kid yet but i
have to be able to make the decision
without any um
without any bias she can't she has to be
open-minded and
motivated someone who's lazy is just not
gonna
do it has to be fit too i'm not
i'm not doing fat [ __ ] i learned my
last step
how how um could she be taller i mean
you're pretty tall what if she was like
six
three six four that'd be [ __ ] cool
that's some dumb ass kid
so you'd be cool a girl is taller than
you you're literally a girl
she was like driven oh yeah she i'm her
little kid
he's pretty tall so it's we're pretty we
we make him big in this family
okay i think that's all my manners oh do
you
think it's a turn off if a girl is like
i hate none like men are trash
have you heard me say that 100 um i'd
sleep with you just for the fact that i
could prove a point of hey
it's not it's not the [ __ ] men that
are trash it's just that you make poor
decision with men
well that's what i always say like when
you as a girl say men are trash
you are communicating i i
sleep around basically that's my
thoughts i get ran through
like i hate to say it i don't want to be
the one to say it
but i can't stand those those people and
like
same thing goes for guys that say women
are trash again
do you guys say that i've heard a few
but they're
usually because of a former breakup or
something
something okay do you think that players
like
do you think of the biggest f boy you
know
cheater okay do you feel like he was
made to be a cheater or born a cheater
like do you think did he get his heart
broken and became a cheater
or did he was he just made i think it's
lack of control
i think it's you made yourself you just
you don't have
discipline and self self um
responsibility you don't take
responsibility for your actions and
self control okay would you be cool if
you were dating a girl
and she went out to parties every
weekend
you're in college so that's pretty
normal in college but i'd say post
college that's not super normal
yeah um i could see it in the future
being a problem but like i just
i wouldn't really care as long as i
trusted her if
if she ever put the doubt in my mind
it'd make me nervous what if she was
wearing a super revealing
outfit would you be cool with that
because i feel like
the only reason that she would wear that
is to get attention
i want attention too i don't give a [ __ ]
we want attention so you don't care if
she like flirts with other guys or gets
attention from other guys as long as
she's not like hooking up with them
doing anything with them if she's
if she's even making out with them
that's too far but well
no no i meant like just like oh my god
you're so funny brad
you know yeah i don't give a [ __ ] brad's
gonna buy her [ __ ] four drinks and
she
my tab's gonna go down because of it
that's the funny thing in the man of
spirit they're very like
insecure about like girls going out and
stuff and
i don't even think it's necessarily for
bad reasons a lot of girls do cheat
so um you know fair enough but isn't it
about 50 50. like because i thought it
was both ways it's about even
um so according to the nanosphere it's
men do slightly higher but by like three
percent it's about 25
to 28. yeah which i mean that's they're
about the same number
and i would guess it's probably half if
you accounted like flirting and stuff
um i like i feel like when people think
cheating they think like have i kissed
or like done anything
i mean i agree i mean that's what it is
you can flirt
all you want like it improves how you
are
as just in general day-to-day
relationships as well as
you can flirt really well and then like
you can relay that back to your
significant other that's just even more
fun
just things to practice i don't know i
would not be cool with the flirting
i'm too i'm too jealous i do not if
you're doing it in front of me then yeah
i'm gonna be like hey
[ __ ] chill um
behind my back i'm not gonna ever figure
it out because i just don't care
um part of it is i don't care enough to
actually look into it and be if i'm
dating you i trust you
there's there's a level of trust like i
i don't date people in general
usually just because i don't trust many
people but if i'm trusting you to date
that i'm gonna trust you to be able to
go out on your own and do [ __ ] on your
own and
i'm gonna trust you to be able to not
cheat on me and have the control and the
cheater the girls that have cheated on
you you've cut off like
it's not like he drug them along or did
anything like that like he
he said no no no no no
okay that's all my manosphere questions
for today but let me know in the
comments if you guys like this segment
and let me know other questions that i
should ask my other brothers
adam's one of them um i have three other
brothers i'm gonna bring on
um also i'm going to bring out them back
at some point so let me know in the
comments what questions that we should
talk about
next bye guys